here is a bit more from Democrats trying
to censor RFK at a censorship hearing
every statement that you just made about
me is inaccurate at one point you say
I'm antifax and that's a bad thing the
other thing the other moment you point
out that all my children are facts I
took flu vaccines for 20 years straight
I have never been anti-vaxx these are
defamations and malignancies that are
used to censor me to prevent people from
listening to the actual things that I'm
saying trusting the experts is not a
function of science it's not a function
of democracy it's a function of religion
and totalitarianism and it does not make
for healthier population I move that we
would move into executive session
because Mr Kennedy has repeatedly made
Despicable anti-semitic and anti-asian
comments is it the custom of this
committee to censor viewpoints that we
disagree with from Witnesses Mr chairman
that's not a point of order on the table
this is an attempt to censor a
censorship hearing
the the charges in this and and by the
way censorship is antithetical to our
party it was at it was appalling to my
father to my uncle to FDR Harry Truman
the Thomas Jefferson we have to stop
trying to destroy each other to
marginalize to vilify to Gaslight each
other we have to find that place inside
of ourselves of light of empathy of
compassion
and he's trying he's trying you think
it's easy to do what he's doing again
whether I agree with him or disagree
with him and in my interview we
disagreed on a bunch of stuff right we
disagree on affirmative action that was
very clear that's just one example but
you think it's easy to do what he's
doing to get up there and sit with these
people under oath and they lie about you
and they try to stop you from speaking
at a censorship hearing as in essence
all you're saying is can we talk about
these things can we question these
things just because Pharmaceuticals
companies say something or the NIH say
something that does not mean it is true
it does not mean in fact can we talk
about that and they trying to cut him
off they're trying to cut him off who
are the good guys and who are the bad
guys again put aside whoever you're
thinking of voting for next time around
put aside whether you usually vote
Republican or usually vote Democrat like
there is something else Brewing right
now and I I don't know exactly what we
do with it but if we can piece this
thing together it can become something
really really important and Powerful
that will trans send politics